I think you wrote an essay called escape
from fantasy to characterize what you
thought the essence of science fiction
was most people think it's a flight into
fantasy I think the title is escape to
reality escape to reality I'm sorry
well that's because you see when you
think of the future you try to make it
as plausible as possible back in 1933
for instance there was science fiction
stories dealing with a world in which
all the oil and coal had been burned up
well the youngsters who read that story
in 1933 including myself took it
seriously at least I did and I said my
goodness what happens if we do burn up
all the oil and coal that's the first
time that ever occurred to me that this
might be a problem so that on and off I
worried about using up our fossil fuel
supplies for the last 40 years and most
of the world virtually all the world has
only started worrying about it a few
months ago you know I read a comment
recently by a Russian scientist about an
HG Wells story it's called when the
sleeper wakes the hero awake who has
gone to gone to sleep in London in 1900
wakes up 200 years later
in 2100 and he finds that London's power
is being supplied by huge wind powered
machines over London and their airplanes
about the size of the first dc-dc trees
and the scientists comment was the
imagination of science fiction writers
is certainly limited well that's true
back in 1848 Edgar Allen Poe wrote a
story set a thousand years in the future
in 2848 and in it he had transatlantic
aeronautical voyages only in balloons
going a hundred miles an hour in other
words in his day there were balloons so
his vision of the future was of faster
balloons
therefore a New Guinea native thought of
a future in which you could communicate
between continents he think of very loud
drums you see it's very difficult really
to visualize the real future well this
raises the question of why science fixed
writers are constantly going into outer
space and to the moon and past them to
the planets do they go there because
that's where the future is going to be
or was going to be or or do they go
there because as a device of the
novelist to set up a controlled
environment I suppose is a little truth
in both the entire history of mankind
has been that of crossing the hilltop to
see what's in the next Valley mankind
has been exploring the earth over
thousands of years
somehow just because we have now
explored the entire earth even
Antarctica and Greenland it seems a
shame to stultify this impulse of ours
and the next thing to explore is the
moon and the planets that's one thing
it's sort of an analogy from the past
and extrapolation forward but then
another thing the environments on these
other planets are made to order for our
purposes strange environments the
possibility of new forms of life this
takes the place of stories in the old
days about mysterious islands in the
Pacific or hidden civilizations in the
Amazon Valley and so on you couldn't
produce that kind of heightened
consciousness if you set your story in
New York City for instance no it gives
us an interesting background and then of
course no matter how strange the
background is what goes on in the
foreground should if it's a good story
illuminate the human condition
you